the last video was very abstract in
general and I used you know f of X and G
of T and H of T what I want to do in
this video is do an actual example so
let's say I have f of X Y let's say that
f of X Y is equal to X Y and let's say
that we have a path in the XY plane or
curve in the xy-plane I'm going to
define my curve say my curve is going to
be defined by X being equal to cosine of
T and Y being equal to sine of T and
we're going to go from it's not you know
we have to define what what are our
boundaries on our T and we're going to
go from T is equal to 0 or or T is going
to be greater than or equal to 0 and
then less than or equal to we're going
to deal in radians PI over 2 if this was
degrees that would be 90 degrees so
that's our curve and immediately you
might already know what this type of a
curve looks like and I'm going to draw
that really fast right here and then
we'll try to visualize this I've
actually grafted ahead of time so that
we can visualize this so this curve
right here if I were to just draw it in
the standard XY plane let me do that in
a different color so we can make the
curve green so let's say that is y and
that this is right here X so when T is
equal to 0 X is going to be equal to
cosine of 0 cosine of 0 is 1 Y is going
to be equal to sine of 0 which is 0 so T
is equal to 0 we're going to be at X is
equal to 1 right that's cosine of 0 and
Y is sine of 0 or Y is going to be 0 so
we're going to be right there that's at
t is equal to t is equal to 0 when T is
equal to PI of 2 what's going to happen
cosine of PI over 2 right that's the
angle cosine of PI over 2 is 0 sine of
PI over 2 is 1 so we're going to be at
the point 0 1 so this is when we're at T
is equal to PI over 2 and you might
recognize what we're going to draw is
actually the first quadrant of the unit
circle when T is equal to PI over 4 or
45 degrees we're going to be at square
root of 2 square root of 2 you can try
it out for your
self but we're just going to have a
curve that looks like this it's going to
be the top right of a circle of the unit
circle it's going to have radius one and
we're going to go in that direction from
T is equal to zero to T is equal to PI
over two that's what this curve looks
like but in the last our goal isn't here
just to graph a parametric equation what
we want to do is raise a fence out of
this kind of base and rise it to this
surface so let's see if we can do that
or at least visualize it first and then
we'll use the tools we use in the last
video so right here I've graphed I've
graphed this function and I've done it
I've rotated a little bit so you could
see the other case this right here let
me get some dark colors out that right
there is the x-axis that's the x-axis
that in the back is the y-axis and the
vertical axis is the z axis and this is
actually two this is one right here y
equal one is right there so this is it
graph that way so if I were to graph
this contour and the XY plane it would
be under this graph and it would go like
something like this let me see if I can
draw it it would look something like
this this would be on the XY plane this
is the same exact graph f of X is equal
to XY let me make that clear this is f
of X f of XY is equal to XY that's both
of these I just rotated it in this
situation this is now that right there
is now the x axis I've rotated to the
left you can kind of imagine that right
there's the x axis that right there is
the y axis it was rotated closer to me
that's the z axis and then this curve if
I were to draw it in this rotation if I
were to draw it in this rotation it's
going to look like this when T is equal
to 0 where it X is equal to 1 Y is equal
to 0 it's going to form a unit circle
something like our half or quarter of a
unit circle like that and when T is
equal to PI over 2 we're going to get
there and what we want to do is find the
area of the curtain that's defined so
let's see let's raise a curtain from
this curve up to f of X Y so if we keep
raising walls from this up to X of Y
we're going to have a wall that looks
something like that
gonna have a wall that looks something
like that let me shade it in colored in
so it looks a little bit more
substantive
so a wall that looks something like that
if I were to try to do it here this
would be under the ceiling but the the
wall would look something like that
right there we want to find the area of
that we want to find the area of this
right here where the base is defined by
this curve and then the ceiling is
defined by this surface here XY which I
just which I graphed and I rotated in
two situations now in the last video we
came up with a well you could argue
whether it's simple but the idea is well
let's just take small arc lengths change
in arc lengths and multiply them by the
height multiply them by the height at
that point and those small change in arc
lengths we call them D s and then the
height is just f of X Y at that point
and we'll take an infinite sum of these
from T is equal to 0 to t equal to PI
over 2 and then that should give us the
area of this wall of this wall right
there so what we said is well to figure
out the area of that we're just going to
take the integral from T is equal to 0
to T is equal to PI over 2 it doesn't
make a lot of sense when I write it like
this of f of X Y times or let me be even
better instead of writing f of X Y let
me just write the actual function let's
get a little bit more concrete
so f of XY is XY x so the particular XY
times the little change in our arc
length of that point I'm going to be
very hand wavy here this is all a little
bit of review of the last video and we
figured out in the last video this
change in arc length right here this
change in arc length D s we figured out
that we could rewrite that as the square
root of DX versus or the derivative of X
with respect to T squared plus the
derivative of Y with respect to T
squared and then all of that times DT
and so I'm just rebuilding the formula
that we got in the last video so this
expression can be re-written as the
integral from t is equal to 0 to T is
equal to PI over 2 times X Y but you
know what
right right from the get-go we want
everything of entry to be in terms of T
so instead of an at we instead of
writing
x times y let's substitute the
parametric form so instead of X let's
write cosine of T so let me write cosine
of T right that is X X is equal to
cosine of T on this curve right X that's
how we define X in terms of the
parameter T and then times y which we're
saying is sine of T times sine of T
that's our Y all I redid all I did is
rewrote X Y in terms of T times D s D s
is this it's the square root it's the
square root of the derivative of X with
respect to T squared plus the derivative
of Y with respect to T squared all of
that times DT and now we just define
these two derivatives and it might seem
really hard but it's very easy for us to
find the derivative of X with respect to
T and the derivative of Y with respect
to T I can do it right or down here let
me we'll lose our graphs for a little
bit so we have we know that the
derivative of X with respect to T is
just going to be what's the derivative
of cosine of T well that's minus sine of
T and the derivative of Y with respect
to T derivative of Y with respect to T
derivative of sine of anything it's the
cosine of that anything so it's cosine
cosine of T and we could substitute
these back into this equation so are the
remember we're just trying to find the
area of this curtain with that has our
curve here is kind of its base and has
this function the surface as its ceiling
so we go back down here and let me
rewrite this whole thing so this becomes
the integral from T is equal to 0 to T
is equal to PI over 2 I don't like this
color of cosine of T sine of T cosine
times sine that's just the X Y times D s
which is this expression right here and
now we can write this as I'll go switch
back to that color I don't like the
square root of the derivative of X with
respect to T is minus sine of t minus
sine of T and we're going to square it
plus derivative of Y with respect to T
that's
of T and we're going to square it maybe
my radical a little bit bigger and then
all of that times DT now this still
might seem like a really hard integral
until you realize that this right here
when you take a negative number and you
square it this is the same thing let me
rewrite - let me do this in the side
right here - sine of T squared plus a
cosine of T squared this is equivalent
to this is the same thing as sine of T
squared plus cosine of T squared right
you lose the sine information when you
square something it just becomes a
positive so these two things are
equivalent and this is the most basic
trig identity this comes straight out of
the unit circle definition sine squared
plus cosine squared this is just equal
to one so all this stuff under the
radical sign is just equal to one and
we're taking the square root of one
which is just one so all of this stuff
right here will just become it'll just
become one and so this whole crazy
integral simplify is a good bit it just
equals the square root T equals zero to
T is equal to PI over 2 of and I'm going
to switch these round just because it'll
make it a little easier in the next step
of sine of T times cosine of T sine of T
times cosine of T DT all I did this
whole thing equals one got rid of it and
I just switch the order of that it'll
make the next step a little bit easier
to explain now this integral is hey sine
times cosine what's the antiderivative
of that and the first thing you should
recognize is hey I have I have a a
function or an expression here and I
have its derivative the derivative of
sine is cosine of T so you might be able
to do u substitution in your head it's a
good skill to be able to do in your head
but I'll do it very explicitly here so
if you have something as derivative you
define that something is u so you say u
is equal to sine of T and then D u DT
the derivative of U with respect to T is
equal to cosine of T or if you multiply
both sides by the differential DT
if we're not going to be too rigorous
you get D U is equal to cosine of T DT
and notice right here I have a U and
then cosine of T DT this thing right
here that thing is equal to D of U and
then we just have to redefine the
boundaries when T is equal to zero
let me so we're going to have this thing
is going to turn into the integral
instead of T is equal to zero when T is
equal to zero what is u equal to sine of
zero is zero so this goes from U is
equal to zero when T is PI over two T is
PI over 2 sine of PI over 2 is 1 so when
T is PI over 2 U is equal to 1 so from U
is equal to 0 to U is equal to 1 just
redid the boundaries in terms of U and
then we have instead of sine of T I'm
going to write U and instead of cosine
of T DT I'm just going to write D U and
now this is a super easy integral in
terms of U this is just equal to the
antiderivative of U is U 1/2 times u
squared right we just raised the
exponent and then divided by that raised
exponent so 1/2 u squared and we're
going to evaluate it from 0 to 1 and so
this is going to be equal to 1/2 times 1
squared minus 1/2 times 0 squared which
is equal to 1/2 times 1 minus 0 which is
equal to 1/2 so we did all that work and
we got a nice simple answer the area the
area of this curtain we just performed a
line integral the area of this curtain
along along this curve right here is
that area let me do it in a darker color
is 1/2 you know if this was in
centimeters would be 1/2 centimeter
squared so I think that was you know a
pretty neat application of the line
integral